et pour en parler nous sommes avec
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude blanche
maison on a vu que la situation était
très critique en inde un l'inde qui
recherchent aussi des vaccins qui
utilisent même le vaccin russe pourtant
le pays a une très grosse capacité de
production
oui les indiens ont développé les plus
grosses capacités de production de
vaccins dans le nom d'ailleurs
traditionnellement l'inde approvisionne
l'organisation mondiale de la santé et
les organisations devenu qui vaccinent
massivement en afrique / pour toutes
sortes de maladies et c'est la même
chose donc pour les vaccins contre le le
govic 19 alors d'ailleurs l'un d'eux a
approuvé depuis quelques temps déjà
depuis le début de l'année un vaccin
indien qui a été fabriqué en ahl qui a
été inventé en inde
et puis par ailleurs elle a un accord
avec des fabricants de l'astra et des
cas pour fabriquer ce vaccin dans une
usine à d pour des quantités tout à fait
importante et eau à partir d'aujourd'hui
il ya donc le beau location du vaccin
russe spoutnik v et j'ai noté que le le
dirigeant de de la société qui a financé
ce vaccin rue datas cité russe qui a
financé ce vaccin a déjà passé au cours
des mois précédents cinq accords de
fabrication avec des grands laboratoires
pharmaceutiques indiens qui sont
d'ailleurs des entreprises privées et
que 100 millions par ci de 100 millions
par là en tout c'est près de 900
millions de doses qui vont être
fabriqués par ses laboratoires indiens
alors évidemment il va falloir le temps
les fabriquer certaines doses seront
prêtes dans les prochaines semaines
d'autres seront prêtes au mois de
juillet mais c'est en effet un résultat
important et n'a rien d'un body comme
vous l'avez dit a promis de vacciner 400
millions da
1 d'ici le mois de juillet il a déjà
atteint le niveau de 100 millions mais
comme vous l'avez dit aussi la
population indienne et est extrêmement
nombreuses et il ouvre cet axe inacio à
tous les indiens qui ont un âge au
dessus de 45 ans à partir de maintenant
donc il a besoin évidemment de tous les
vaccins possible et cela est un élément
de la lutte contre la pandémie mais ça
n'est pas le seul justement quel est
l'autre stratégie mise à part les
vaccins du pays alors narendra modi a
exposé sa stratégie à la télévision pour
expliquer à tous les indiens que en
effet ensemble ils avaient vaincu la
première vague en réalité narendra modi
avait décidé il ya un an d'un
confinement très dur de tout le pays
en utilisant de ces pouvoirs
exceptionnels dus à la pandémie et
pendant près de deux mois
l'économie indienne s'est arrêté les
travailleurs précaires parce qu'il ya
beaucoup il ya un secteur informel qui
est très important l'un sont retournés
dans le désordre dans leurs campagnes et
l'économie a été mise à plat pendant
cette période alors il a expliqué hier à
la télévision qu'il ne s'agissait pas de
refaire la même chose bien entendu
puisque cette fois ci on a les vaccins
et que par conséquent il recommandait un
confinement spécifique 1 micron
confinement par dans les zones qui sont
particulièrement touchés il a également
recommandé un couvre-feu pour la nuit et
un certain nombre d'autres mesures qui
sont grosso modo celle qui sont
appliquées dans différents pays d'europe
mais la grande différence avec la france
en tout cas c'est que l'inde est un pays
fédéral et que la compétence sanitaire
revient aux 22 états et que le centre
des lilas de pouvoir direct que sur neuf
sujets qui sont dirait qu'ils dépendent
directement de la capitale donc il faut
convaincre les chief minister des
différents des 22 états et c'est ce à
quoi s'emploie monsieur maudit un petit
peu comme
madame merkel le fait avec les ministres
en chef avec les ministres présidents
des différents länder et ça n'est pas
simple mais la pandémie gagne puisque
bombay a décidé c'est le gouvernement du
maharashtra qu'il a décidé d'un
confinement alors qu'il s'agit de la
capitale économique et financière du
pays et que d'autres villes sont en
train de faire la même chose des lits et
20 qu'alors la capitale delà de la
technologie et de l'informatique ont
décidé d'un couvre-feu et d'un black out
pendant les week-ends ou moins pendant
un mois donc on a une situation
d'urgence qui va marcher sur deux pieds
d'un confinement sélectif et puis les
vaccinations les vaccinations à outrance
puisque le pays en a le moins les moyens
quelles conséquences économiques et
politiques de cette stratégie du premier
ministre alors la conséquence économique
que ça d'abord était que le confinement
d'il ya un an a provoqué une baisse de
la production une baisse du pib de
l'inde de 20% ce qui est considérable
mais l'économie étant suffisamment
flexibles l'inde a retrouvé le niveau
d'avant
ce confinement est donc d'avant la
pandémie dès le mois dernier et par
conséquent avec un taux de croissance
pas que le fonds monétaire international
prévoyez pour l'année 2000 21 un taux de
croissance de 12 et 10 % pour l'économie
indienne
mais ça c'était avant la deuxième vague
et avant les mesures qui sont en train
d'être prises dans les grandes villes et
dans les grands centres où il ya un
regain de contagion alors la première
conséquence ça va être celle ci est
effectivement le jeu pour les
responsables est de doser le confinement
sans arrêter l'économie est un peu le
problème qu'on a connu et qu'on pouvait
l'on connaît encore dans nos pays dans
nos pays européens et puis l'autre
conséquence politique c'est que
l'inde avait promis de distribuer des
vaccins gratuitement aux pays voisins
notamment aux deux pays l'himalaya le
népal et le bhoutan mais aussi ses pays
voisins de l'est ce que sont le
bangladesh et la birmanie
et puis aux îles que sont les villes
d'agde livres ou même un peu plus loin
l'île maurice 20 millions de zone
gratuitement et que là devant la
pandémie l'inde a été obligé de
d'interdire les exportations de vaccins
la priorité c'est de vacciner les
indiens et par conséquent bien jeu
malheureusement les doses qui était
promise à l' oms ou à d'autres
organisations devenu bien est le seul
organisme devront attendre pour les pour
les recevoir
sur le plan politique c'est plus
difficile parce que l'inde connaît
actuellement des élections dans
plusieurs grands états notamment au west
bengal et calcutta et calcutta a
toujours voté depuis 30 ans pour des
chief minister d'opposition gouvernement
de delhi quels qu'ils soient est
actuellement vallat mamata banerjee
cherche à obtenir un troisième mandat et
se bat dans une élection qui dure
plusieurs semaines parce que il faut
faire voter 80 des millions de personnes
et se bat contre un candidat bjp et
soutenue par le premier ministre n'a
rien bravo dit et je pense que dans ces
conditions il retrouve la même chose au
terral arts ou la même chose au tamil
nadu
les partis politiques ne voudront sans
doute pas faire ce que narendra modi
leur demande c'est à dire une sorte
d'union nationale pour traiter la
pandémie là la politique a aussi ses
droits est évidemment l'un d'études très
grande démocratie et il faut que les
élections se tiennent dans ces trois ou
quatre états comme cela a été planifié
merci expert en relations
internationales merci d'avoir été avec
nous restez avec nous